[Musica]
ascolto
l'ascolto è un'azione un atto creativo
l'ascolto non semplicemente di un
discorso di una canzone di una musica ma
anche l'ascolto di un paesaggio sonoro
di quello che c'è in mezzo alle parole
di quello che c'è sotto le parole che di
quello che le parole fanno risuonare in
noi un ascolto intenzionale come
cantautore come musicista ho imparato
che l'ascolto è la mia arma più potente
prima ancora
dell'eventuale capacità di comporre di
esprimermi di cantare e l'ascolto
intenzionale e profondo è un esercizio
di libertà
questa è una delle prime elezioni che ho
imparato dalla musica e dall'ascolto e
l'ho imparata in un carcere tempo fa
sono stato chiamato a tenere un concerto
per le detenute del carcere femminile
della giudecca a venezia e dopo che ha
suonato per loro
tra una domanda e l'altra
abbiamo pensato che sarebbe stato
interessante provare a scrivere una
canzone tutti insieme certo sulle prime
c'era un po di diffidenza ma come ci
stai prendendo in giro noi non abbiamo
mai fatto musica ma poi come si fa a
scrivere una canzone eravamo in 30
in quel momento ho detto no secondo me
tra queste mura c'è una canzone che
suona c'è una canzone che risuona basta
ascoltarle tirarla fuori come si fa non
lo so proviamo così voi decidete di cosa
parlare ha detto alle donne loro hanno
avuto una risposta univoca
immediata libertà scrivere una canzone
sulla libertà è difficile scriverla
all'interno di un carcere è ancora più
difficile perché la libertà lì la devi
cercare nascosta in filigrana la devi
vedere nei suoi opposti la devi vedere
nella sofferenza nella sottrazione dalla
distanza
la prima cosa che abbiamo fatto quel
giorno è stata mettere su un foglio
27 parole tante quante erano le ragazze
che stavano partecipando a
quell'incontro chiesto loro di scrivere
di getto la prima parola che gli venisse
in mente pensando alla libertà
sono uscito dal carcere su un carro sul
vaporetto ho guardato quell elenco di
parole diversissime tra loro e mi sono
accorto che avevo un sacco di mattoni
mattoncini ma non avevo il progetto
della casa non avevo le fondamenta non
avevo la calce per tenerli insieme non
avevo ancora ascoltato e ho capito che
sarei dovuto tornare ancora e ancora e
ancora
per capire cosa c'era tra quelle mura e
cosa c'era in mezzo a quelle parole
quindi mi sono incontrato varie volte
con le donne e le ho ascoltate perché
dovevo essere testimone di una realtà
che non era la mia dovevo custodire
qualcosa tradurre qualcosa ascoltare poi
una sera a milano ero a casa mia avevo
di fronte il foglio ci eravamo già visti
un'altra infinità di volte e ha detto
bene arrivato il momento ho composto un
brano e l'ho intitolato nonostante tutto
pochi giorni dopo
sono ritornato nel carcere della
giudecca nella mia attività di musicisti
di cantautore mi è capitato di suonare
in contesti abbastanza
imponenti suggestivi o di fronte a un
pubblico molto ampio ma raramente ho
avuto così tanta ansia così tanto timore
e mi sono sentito così tanta aspettativa
addosso proprio perché dovevo dimostrare
il rispetto dell'ascolto e le ragazze
non hanno mancato di farmelo notare una
in particolare
denis che era tra le più spigliate mi ha
detto appena sono entrato nel carcere ho
varcato la soglia da sono venute
accogliere mi ha detto spero che tu
abbia scritto una buona canzone perché
qua dentro ci siamo noi non ci sei tu
ho iniziato a suonare mi sono fatto
forza ho cantato la prima strofa a occhi
chiusi ho cantato il ritornello che ho
visto che qualcuna delle mie coautrici
si era commossa qualcun'altra rideva al
secondo ritornello stavamo cantando
tutti insieme
allora a quel punto
ho capito non ho ho scritto una bella
canzone ma forse ho ascoltato nel modo
giusto
forse ho ascoltato nel modo giusto
quello che risuonava tra le mura e
quello che c'era in mezzo alle parole
mi faccio ascoltare questo brano che si
chiama nonostante tutto
[Musica]
e la sopportazione
ha finito dentro una canzone
bisogna respirare la speranza mezzo alla
tempesta
la metà
[Musica]
non sbaglia
voglio sapere che mi ha perdonato
lombardi in faccia che tutto è cambiato
a porta
[Musica]
ciao
abarth
era fare
nel cassetto e ascoltare
[Musica]
essere felici che per sottrazione per
prendere dalla disperazione
[Musica]
si
parte
esserle arjen dio delle piccole cose
spostare la tristezza
[Musica]
voglio
che tutto è cambiato
[Musica]
c'era
no
[Musica]
mi
piace
la cristina
accettata
sesso l'odore portata dal vento
ha espresso
[Musica]
c'ero più tua
senza
[Musica]
gambe che con il cuore che respira e
nonostante tutto
su 10
dammi le ha
[Musica]
la libertà
che cosa si
no
la seconda
la seconda lezione che ho imparato dalla
musica e dall'ascolto ho imparato sui
luoghi
ogni luogo ogni paesaggio sonoro ha una
sua impronta digitale un suo timbro
vocale
indistinguibile da tutti gli altri non
si può non ci sono due posti che suonano
nello stesso modo ogni posto
propaga il suono lo assorbe lo trasmette
in modo diverso l'ho scoperto facendo il
mio secondo disco registrandolo in una
stanza scavata in uno scoglio a picco
sul mar ligure abbiamo lasciato le
finestre le finestre la finestra aperta
abbiamo registrato dal vivo e il mare è
entrato a raccontare la sua storia nelle
canzoni e io ora non potrei riascoltare
quelle canzoni senza sentire la storia
di quei posti di quel mare di quel
momento e ho deciso di giocare con
questa cosa in un altro
in un'altra impresa un po folle che ho
fatto nella mia attività di cantautore
qualche anno fa ho preso uno zaino una
chitarra più piccola di questa sono
partito dalla mia città a milano
e sono arrivato a piedi fino a roma
lungo la via francigena
suonando un concerto ogni due giorni
ma non ho mai avuto amplificazione ogni
posto dove mi sono fermato doveva
suonare come se stesso doveva far
riecheggiare la sua storia e ha suonato
in posti diversissimi tra loro in una
yurta mongola in una casa di riposo in
una legatoria sul bancone di un bar in
un tempio buddista in mezzo un bosco in
una piazza vuota in una piazza piena di
gente
ma non aveva amplificazione quindi io
suonavo insieme al luogo che mi ospitava
che spesso il volume richiedeva un
ascolto diverso e in più io ero un
cantastorie
raccoglievo le storie per strada di chi
si univa al cammino con me chi mi
seguiva per varie tappe di sconosciuti
portavo le mie storie ma ascoltavo le
storie degli altri perciò nessun
concerto è stato uguale ad un altro
e stata una dimensione di ascolto
spazioso sono tornato sono arrivato a
roma con uno zaino pieno di cose che
avevo ascoltato e non sapevo ancora che
sarebbero diventate canzoni e di più
altra lezione che ho imparato si ascolta
con tutti i sensi quando sia per strada
sia metaforicamente che concretamente se
tu la strada al ascolti anche con i tuoi
piedi
porta esattamente a casa dove dovrai
arrivare e questa canzone parla proprio
di questo si chiama del road
la spezia
[Musica]
ma equa
bastico
[Musica]
sì
no
[Musica]
oggi
no
[Musica]
tracce
ma
c'è un'altra c'è un'altra lezione che ho
imparato
sempre in questo viaggio vi ho
raccontato accennato al fatto che a un
certo punto mi sono ritrovato a suonare
in un gompa un tempio buddista
a pomaia all'istituto lama tzong khapa
mi sono trovato inaspettatamente a
suonare di fronte a dei monaci ea delle
monache le mie canzoni
e ho percepito un ascolto diverso da
qualsiasi ascolto
io abbia mai esperito prima cioè le mie
parole cadevano in uno spazio dove non
c'era reattività
non c'era ascolto e reagisco all'impulso
c'era uno spazio enorme che è quello
spazio di libertà che mi sono accorto di
aver sempre cercato nell'ascolto e di
cui parlavamo prima è che c'è in ogni
luogo ed è sempre disponibile e c'è
anche adesso
ed è sempre sempre diverso
ed è sempre sempre inimitabile ma è
sempre a disposizione
e ci sono dentro mille canzoni mille
storie perciò io adesso vi invito a fare
una cosa visto che ne abbiamo parlato
dell'aspetto
chiudiamo gli occhi per qualche istante
ci limitiamo a respirare e va tutto bene
quello che sentiamo sarà la nostra
canzone a partire da adesso
è questa qua la nostra casa ed è sempre
disponibile grazie
[Applauso]